i know you are a huge fan of westerns
obviously so you are trapped on a desert
island what are the two or three that
you take with you that that's it that's
all you can have okay the first i always
say is uh
for a few dollars more
right it was the audaciousness of that
movie sergio leon's uh the second time
he used clint eastwood the first time
clint eastwood and lee vancleef uh uh
met then jean-marie vellante who was the
baddie in the first one is the baddie in
the second one like he died in the first
one playing basically the exact same guy
just awesome i'll take that um
first i would probably take
unforgiven
police was unforgiving the amount of
times i've watched that movie even with
the kind of narrow portrayals of
everyone else
that shootout at the end
is just
wicked
and then i'll go old school
maybe james stewart winchester 73 i
think that movie just makes me think of
my mom and my dad
um
no
i'll take
the man who shot liberty valance
lee marvin james stewart john wayne
woody strode
strother martin a young lee van
so those three
uh good choices um i want to start with
regarding your movie uh congratulations
i had a blast watching it and i also
want to thank netflix for making it
because it's about freaking time stories
like this are told um when you were
researching to write this
what what do you think is like the
biggest surprise that people don't know
that you wanted to make sure got
incorporated into your film about the
old west well in learning about the old
um the old west and more characters and
more uh
lives and lifestyles um in the old west
i you know i was doing that growing up
the biggest um
surprise were were
how many cowboys were actually black
like
something like one in four cowboys were
of color um that was a huge surprise but
also how many amazing
colorful
um
uh
human beings
there were the western was always given
to us for for a wider scope when people
leave the harder they fall
whether you know whatever their feeling
is it will now be broader they'll know
that stagecoach mary really existed
gertrude smith really existed rufus buck
nat love bill pickett and that was the
biggest surprise um cherokee bill cathay
williams jim beckwith wiley esco bass
reeves the biggest surprise of of uh
the
me learning about the oldest and what i
learned about it
was not how much how many of these
characters they were but actually their
contributions like best reeves is the
the inspiration for the lone ranger
the actual contributions in in
everything that hollywood um
portrayed and kind of removed
uh i hope people walk away from the
holiday fall
just feeling uh more of a sense of uh
of
self who we were back then not just
black people everyone who we
were back then just as a human race
what did you learn making they die by
dawn that really helped you make this
film
i think firstly
making uh they die by doing my short
film i learned um
a lot i learned
a lot about um actors and their and
their process um working with such as uh
steamed greats like the late great
michael k williams giancarlo esposito
isaiah washington one of my favorite
actors of all time um nate parker uh
jesse williams uh
rosario dawson eric badu
i learned
a lot about actors their process how to
how to um
work with them and what to expect
basically no games on set when they when
they arrive they are in
total character um
and i learned
i learned a lot about like just working
with horses there weren't many horses in
in they died by dawn as much as they are
in the harder they fall but just working
with horses and
new things i'll never know like some
actors are allergic to horses
and just
all of that kind of stuff but the
environment of the old west
was so kind of second nature to me it
all just seemed real when i when i got
there that i took with me to the holiday
for like this is real let's just shoot
on location and
and and also how much shooting on
location
um uh aids the actors and the and the
crew it makes you really feel like you
were there in that space in that space
and time so even when you're on lunch
break you're still in the old west um uh
that stuff was great
uh
every western has a big third act
shootout obviously your film has a third
act shootout uh talk about what you
wanted uh in your third act shootout and
maybe the challenges of putting it
together
what i wanted in my third act shootout
was super high octane um uh
action
but also like storylines converging and
to give us something we've never seen
before like like stagecoach mary versus
trudy smith i've just not seen that in a
in a western on that
on that level
um
where the women are just as powerful
as the men the body counts are high on
on every side and also doing something
musically with it that i've never um
seen in a in a western with the usage of
fella cootie and afrobe
and it's all
uh it just all
fits seamlessly in one cohesive uh
uh plate i think that the challenges
of it were
the hard work you know the
i suppose the amount of horses um that
were used when the
when particular things happen without
giving spoilers
and you know shooting around the horses
and having the stunt those things were
challenging but more exciting than
challenging
and also just shooting in coving because
that was crazy
it was it was crazy but we did it
i i [ __ ] i'm almost out of time i have
two more questions um that i really want
to ask uh i'm always obsessed with the
editing because that's where it all
comes together you have some very cool
shots in this movie especially in the
credits the beginning where you use cuts
and still anyway can you sort of talk
about the editing process and um what
were the big challenges you over
overcame or you know if you could talk
about the editing the editing was
amazing you know um i i work with a uh a
person i'm a huge fan of his name is tom
eagles and he edited um what we do in
the shadows jojo rabbit um hunt for the
world of people and his timing and pace
for things for drama and humor and
quirkiness would just fit into
everything and everything i am as a as a
filmmaker and um
and so him and i
when we were editing we're really
approaching this
from a different
angle because it's
heavily music driven as well as it is um
as much as it is dramatic
so finding those um
beats where we we go from song to score
to dialogue to
you know was it was a
was a challenge but like a beautiful
challenge it wasn't a it wasn't a
struggle i think the biggest um
challenge for me was
it being my first time my first feature
is learning to
censor myself the meaning
or learning to edit myself
because i want to keep everything in
there i loved every stage of the movie
the first cup was super long i loved
every stage of it so
learning how to pull back and and edit
uh my own my own um
babies so to speak
was the biggest challenge but we did it
and it was awesome
i'm yeah i was gonna say i'm sure you
have a much longer cut um i have to stop
here i'm just gonna say congrats on the
movie i look forward to whatever you're
gonna be doing next thank you my brother
thank you so much viva collider
thank you have a great day